Lo que haremos en este video es tratar
de desglosar la terminología y un poco
de las matemáticas del seguro de salud. La
primera pregunta que podrías hacerte es:
¿cuánto cuesta un plan de seguro? En muchos
casos es posible que tengas un patrón que
paga la totalidad o una parte de tu seguro, pero
en muchos casos debes obtener tu propio seguro,
así que me voy a centrar en el segundo caso.
Fui al mercado de seguros médicos de mi estado
y busqué un plan indicativo para una familia de
cuatro, que hace un total combinado de 100 mil
pesos al año. Este es sólo uno de los planes
que encontré. Quité el nombre de la compañía,
y lo que tenemos aquí es la prima mensual. Cuando
la gente habla de primas en seguros está hablando
de la cantidad que tienes que pagar para obtener
el seguro, de modo que tienes que pagar 629.51
pesos por mes para obtener este seguro; también lo
puedes escuchar en términos de primas anuales. Y
puedes adivinar cómo pasar de una prima mensual
a una anual: si multiplicas este número 629.51
por 12, obtendrás una prima anual de 7,554.12;
así que esto es lo que alguien tendría que pagar
-probablemente tú- para obtener este seguro. Esto
nos indica que esta es realmente la prima después
de un subsidio bastante grande del gobierno
federal y estatal, y la mayor parte de esto
viene del gobierno federal, pero podemos hablar
de eso en futuros videos. El panorama general aquí
es que si quieres saber cuánto cuesta una póliza,
esta es la prima: esta es la prima mensual y esta
es la prima anual. Ahora, lo siguiente que es
muy probable que revises cuando buscas adquirir
una póliza es un término llamado deducible, y
una forma de pensar en un deducible es lo que
tendrás que pagar de tu propio bolsillo antes de
que el seguro realmente comience a funcionar. Aquí
estamos viendo dos columnas: en la red y fuera
de la red. En la red se encuentran médicos y
proveedores de atención médica que la compañía
de seguros ya ha puesto en su red, con los que
tiene algún tipo de acuerdo; mientras que con los
que están fuera de la red no tiene un acuerdo,
de modo que para esta aseguradora, si vas a
la red, tendrías que gastar hasta 6,300 pesos
por persona antes de que el seguro realmente
comience a funcionar. Entonces, si tuvieras
que hacerte algún tipo de cirugía que cuesta
6,000, incluso si has estado pagando la prima,
tendrías que pagar 6,000 además de la prima para
obtener esa cirugía. Por otro lado, si esa cirugía
para una sola persona, digamos que cuesta 10,300
pesos, bueno, en esta situación tendrías que pagar
los primeros 6,300 -menos 6,300 pesos-, lo que
significa que la compañía de seguros pagaría el
resto, pagaría los 4,000, pesos restantes. Y en
ese año, si tuvieras que hacerte otras cirugías,
digamos que tú eres esa persona, entonces estaría
descubierto, la compañía de seguros pagaría
cualquier cosa por encima de los 6,300 pesos.
Ahora, también tiene un deducible para toda la
familia, entonces no sólo suman lo que gasta cada
individuo también suman lo que está gastando toda
la familia. Digamos que somos 4 personas en mi
familia, y en el transcurso del año, para cada
uno, he gastado 3,150 pesos -estoy haciendo esto
sólo como un ejemplo-, así que ninguno ha llegado
todavía a su deducible individual, pero en total
mi familia de 4 -3,150 x 4 son 12,600 pesos-;
después de este punto, aunque ningún miembro ha
agotado su deducible todavía, el seguro también
se activará. Ahora, cuando hablan de un deducible
de medicamentos, este es un deducible separado
para los medicamentos, entonces el que vimos antes
podría ser para procedimientos generales o ciertos
tipos de atención que podrías necesitar; mientras
que este de aquí es específico, es lo que podrías
necesitar para medicamentos. Pero es la misma
idea: si es para un individuo los primeros 500
pesos en medicamentos en ese año los va a tener
que pagar de su bolsillo, pero después el seguro
entra en acción, y una vez más son 1000 pesos para
toda la familia. Ahora, el desembolso máximo -esto
nos indica que no importa la razón-, nadie de
forma individual tiene que gastar más de 7,800
pesos pase lo que pase y no más de 15,600 pesos
para una familia completa. Esto es dinero real,
pero dice que no tendrás que pagar más que eso
de tu bolsillo. Enseguida tenemos el costo máximo
por receta, esto es el monto máximo que tendrías
que pagar para surtir una receta médica, así que
incluso si hay algún tipo de medicamento exótico
que cuesta 1000 pesos por receta lo máximo que
tendrías que pagar es 500 pesos por receta. Ahora
que hemos diseccionado un poco los deducibles,
otro término que es probable que veas es el
copago. Una forma de pensar en el copago es: algo
que pagas cada vez que solicitas ese servicio,
por ejemplo, una consulta de atención primaria.
Aquí nos dice que hay un copago de 65 pesos en
las primeras tres visitas antes del deducible,
esto quiere decir que incluso si no has usado tu
deducible individual de 6,300 pesos tus consultas
de atención primaria están cubiertas, pero en
cada consulta tendrás que pagar 65 pesos. Ahora,
la razón por la que lo llaman copago es que
tú y la compañía de seguros están pagando,
esa consulta podría costarle a la compañía de
seguros otros 150, 200, 250 pesos, pero tú estás
pagando 65 pesos en cada consulta, entonces la
compañía de seguros está interviniendo incluso
antes de que se haya alcanzado el deducible.
Ahora, la consulta de especialidad. Si vas
con médicos especialistas como un cardiólogo o un
reumatólogo o un dermatólogo, estos copagos sólo
entran después del deducible, lo que significa
que antes de alcanzar tu deducible vas a pagar
de tu bolsillo lo que cuesta la consulta, de
modo que si esa consulta con el especialista
cuesta 500 pesos, vas a pagar 500 pesos, pero
una vez que hayas alcanzado tu deducible,
entonces cada consulta te va a costar 95 pesos,
es con lo que contribuirías, y luego la compañía
de seguros pagaría el resto. Ahora, el último
término que voy a presentar en este video es el
de coseguro. Lo que nos están diciendo es cómo
estamos cubiertos para varios medicamentos. Por
ejemplo, si es un medicamento genérico -son los
medicamentos que están fuera de patente- pagas
18 pesos después de haber alcanzado el deducible,
entonces no importa lo que cuesta el medicamento,
después de haber alcanzado el deducible
por cada receta pagas 18 pesos. Ahora,
estos medicamentos de nivel 2 -y no voy a entrar
en detalle sobre esto, pero estos son medicamentos
que tienden a estar todavía en patente y tienden
a ser más caros- lo que nos dice este coseguro es:
vas a pagar los medicamentos de tu bolsillo hasta
que alcances tu deducible para este plan de seguro
y luego de haber alcanzado el deducible vas a
pagar el 40% del costo. De modo que cuando alguien
habla de coseguro significa que está dividiendo
el costo con la compañía de seguros en este punto,
y generalmente se especifica como un porcentaje,
entonces, lo que pagarías por ese medicamento,
es el 40%. Así que digamos que son 100 pesos
al mes: pagarías el 40%, entonces pagarías 40
pesos y sólo obtendrías el subsidio del 60%
de la compañía de seguros después de que se
haya alcanzado el deducible de tu medicamento.
Lo dejaré allí. Ya he presentado muchas ideas,
pero espero que esto te ayude a comenzar a
entender cómo funcionan los planes de seguro.